hey guys do you know why we as men
sometimes find it a little bit hard to
understand
women
[Music]
well that's because we really are
different
men and women are different not just
physically but also
psychologically so in this video i'm
going to share with you 15
interesting things that make men
different from women let's get to it
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're on my channel welcome
my name is daniel and here i talk about
fitness grooming style and life itself
everything has got to do with men so if
you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the future
videos now let's start with the 15
things that make men
different from women
different skin do you think that a
woman's skin and a man's skin are the
same
well it's not a man's skin is 25 thicker
than a woman's and not only that men
also have higher densities
of collagen which is a kind of protein
[Music]
now here's a very interesting one when
we exercise
do men and women use the same amount of
fat and carbs for
fuel no we don't women use mostly fat
while men
use carbohydrates
[Music]
the heart rates of men and women are the
same
wrong they're different when resting men
have lower resting heart rates than
women
but women got lower peak heart rates
and then when it comes to exercise it's
also different
men's heart rates rise faster and slow
quicker
afterward than women
[Music]
most women are very good at multitasking
while on the other hand
men are better most men are better to
focus in on
one single thing and to do it really
good and that's also why
most men don't like it when they are
interrupted when they are busy
focusing on something according to
psychology today
women perform 70 percent better than men
at juggling more than one task at a time
now here's the interesting one the brain
develops
differently girls develop the right side
of the brain faster
and it's connected to memory talking
vocabulary pronunciation
and reading earlier and then when it
comes to us boys the left side
develops faster and that's connected to
problem solving
perceptual skills math visual spatial
logistical skills building and figuring
out
puzzles
you know when you're in an argument with
someone from the other sex
there are times when you wonder man why
can't they just understand you why can't
you understand
them it happens you can
ask older married couples and they'll
tell you it happens a lot more than you
think
but it happens because we really do
think
differently about things men are usually
more rational
analytic and logical while women are
more intuitive
holistic creative and integrated
[Music]
women are usually more emotional than
men
usually let me be very careful with what
i say here
and they are because they have they're
more in touch with their emotions and
they have a wider range
of emotions and not just that the
intensity of those feelings
are a lot bigger than it is for men and
then
especially in relationships when women
are too emotionally men
find it a little bit irrational and
difficult to understand
but that is what makes us different
[Music]
men are more sensitive to smells and
sounds
wrong women are and not just that women
tend to put
a bigger emphasis on the atmosphere of a
place
and that's why it's important to think
carefully about the location
of a place before you take your woman to
a date
both men and women want the same thing
when we experience
problems well yeah sometimes but
there are certain things that are more
important for the two different genders
women they want empathy more
for men we want to solve the problem we
want
solutions
when it comes to blood we are the same
false men have more red blood cells than
women
not only that women have lower blood
pressure
than that
our fingers are the same
false they are different put your hand
up look at it
the longest finger is this guy here
right the middle finger
what is the second longest finger that
you have
for men it is usually this finger the
ring finger
but for women it is not most women it is
the index finger
men and women process information
differently
because our brains are structured
differently
it's true men have more information
containing gray matter
and on the other hand women have more
white matter
and not just that women also have bigger
memory centers than men
that's why you sometimes get in a fight
with a woman and she remembers things
from 10 years ago
[Music]
you probably already know this but men
we have this guy here
the adam's apple but do you know why
because we have bigger voice boxes and
makes the surrounding cartilage
stick out more
one of the joys of life is to eat tasty
food right but who's got the better
taste
men or women women
women have better senses of smell and
taste
why because they have 50 more cells in
their olfactory bulbs
so what is that exactly well it's the
part in your brain that process
smells and then when it comes to tasting
women
the reason why they taste better than us
guys is because they have more taste but
usually more
[Music]
now a very interesting one do we see the
world the same
no we don't most men can sense movement
better than women
while women can distinguish small
differences in color
better now let me know in the comment
section down below if you know of any
other things that are different between
men and women
it'll be interesting to have a look and
then stick around watch some of my other
videos
here and i'll see you there cheers guys
[Music]